louis es ciudadano estadounidense pero
en acción se crió en venezuela llegó
hace un año al sur de la florida huyendo
de la crisis política y humanitaria en
su país ahora se ha unido a la campaña
de bailén diciendo un compromiso con
apoyar la candidatura
de unos meses para acá porque he visto
la polarización que se ha desarrollado
entre los latinos especialmente los
venezolanos yo yo yo ya viví lo que es
una que es ver familias divididas por
algo político que es ver un país
dividido por algo político
en las últimas semanas ha estado muy
activo en actos del partido demócrata
especialmente en los que tienen que ver
con el voto venezolano quiere acabar con
la falsa creencia de que va a ir en
representa a la izquierda más radical
hay que hacer campaña política hay que
participar porque si uno no participa
otros lo harán y yo he visto qué pasa
cuando la gente deja participar siendo
que además ahí hay una campaña es
información que hay que hay que atacar
al igual que el muchos compatriotas
siendo unidos los demócratas para
defenderse según dicen de la campaña
engañosa de los republicanos en tratando
de repetir una mentira mil veces para
que se convierta en verdad pero
realmente byron no es socialista el voto
venezolano cobra especial relevancia en
esta ciudad rural aquí se concentra la
mayor población venezolana en eeuu un
estudio de la universidad del norte de
florida revela que siete de cada diez
venezolanos en el estado votaría por
trump es el caso de alfredo ortega todas
las peores causas de la humanidad están
detrás de la candidatura del partido
demócrata y cuando uno ve que
efectivamente el partido de nicolás
maduro está apoyando
yo bailé pues es simplemente un descaro
que están convencidos de que el actual
presidente es la mejor opción para sacar
a nicolás maduro del poder con su pasión
único que empuja ordiales de tradiciones
contundentes contra el régimen tirano de
nicolás maduro y yo creo que son más que
elocuentes un exilio el venezolano unido
en su oposición a nicolás maduro pero
dividido frente a la elección
presidencial en su nuevo país